some of our nation's biggest school
districts are considering the ideal of
shutting down in-person classes and
returning to remote learning
the chicago teachers union is reportedly
asking members if they support a
district-wide pause in in-person
learning allowing them to pivot to
online and new york city teachers are
pressuring their unions as well as the
mayor
to bring back remote learning but
outgoing mayor bill de blasio doesn't
seem willing to budge
our schools have been extraordinarily
safe
bluntly the safest places to be in new
york city very low levels of covet
schools need to be open
everyone talks about the needs of our
kids their health needs physical health
mental health nutrition needs their
social development needs their academic
needs schools need to be open
so listen every time i hear headlines
about teachers unions i always take the
time out to remember that teacher unions
are made up of workers and public sector
workers that educators and i've done
some time interviewing educators and
what you see them saying is that we want
to be back in our classrooms but we're
also trying to balance that with the
safety of ensuring that our students
don't get covered and bring it home to
their parents or to grandma so dr
sapphire my question for you is how do
we help both parents and educators
bridge this balance of the importance of
having in-person learning while also
ensuring that these children aren't
spreading covert 19 to their loved ones
back at home
yeah that's a great question and i can
tell you one of the biggest failures of
our entire response throughout the
pandemic is taking children out of
school but the biggest failure is
keeping them out of school the fact that
this is even an option at this point is
a continued failure of us from a federal
level a state level and a local level
under no circumstances should these
schools switch to remote learning unless
there is a very specific need and it is
it is about yes it is about the teachers
getting copin 19 is about the children
getting sick it is about them bringing
home the virus to those around them but
time after time we have now been able to
prove that there is low amount of
transmission in schools no more than
normal flu and cold season we need to
stop stigmatizing normal seasonal
respiratory viruses rsv and flu are very
severe in children so yes if you have a
low or a high absentee where you have
enough children who are out sick often
times they will close down a classroom
so that they can sanitize and give
children time to recover and get back to
the classroom but they shouldn't
preemptively be going to remote learning
in anticipation of positive cases coming
back from the holidays there is no
reason for that we have now gone to a
place where you have an entire
generation of children who have been
have poor
poor performers when it comes to
education they have not had adequate
education they have had poor
socialization and that has been a
complete hindrance to their mental and
physical development it is far more
dangerous to keep them out of school
than bringing them into school when we
know at this point these again continue
to be the lowest risk population when it
comes to covid19 high-risk children and
those that live in homes with high-risk
individuals have the ability to be
vaccinated have the ability to be
boosted and from there it is time to
move forward and let this mild illness
in children
otherwise circulate so that they can get
that immunity and we can continue
keeping them in school because that is
what's best for them long term
thanks dr sapphire so joey i guess my
question to you is this i mean because
there is this profes this prevailing
balance that i think that dr sapphire
laid out there right so how do you
balance educators who want to be with
their with their students when you have
government failure when it comes to
testing contact tracing ensuring that
folks have access to the vaccine
well you know maybe you say get parents
to the school board to advocate for
their children but i guess that's a
cardinal sin now too you'll have the fbi
breathing down your back i guess
the problem now is that we have the you
you talk you opened the segment talking
about how
school um
uni teachers unions are made up of the
worker the person in there with the kids
they the members are but the leaders are
not the leaders are bureaucrats the
leaders are corrupt individuals who now
serve to satisfy themselves and in the
entity and i don't mean that to attack
teachers unions that's what unions have
become in a place where you have
communication it's a lot harder to take
advantage of workers which is what
started the idea of a union to begin
with that's one of the problems in this
country what we need to do is be less
selfish what we haven't learned in two
years is how coronavirus affects
children what we have learned in about a
year is how badly being out of school
affects children so if i'm looking at
those two things face to face i'm gonna
do the unselfish thing put my kids in a
classroom and make sure they have the
social and learning opportunities that
every american needs to survive in this
life nothing affects socioeconomically
underprivileged kids worse nothing
bridges that gap wider than this at home
learning because kids with rich parents
and attentive parents won't have the
same problems that other kids who need
to be in classroom should have the
opportunity and attention
so
so i mean what was your take on that
rachel
well let's start with what joey was
talking about with the unions public
school teachers don't work for the
unions they work for us the taxpayers we
pay their their salaries and that's who
they work for it is very clear when you
have uh mental health uh just
skyrocketing mental health problems
among children um as young as four or
five years old you have a 50
increase in suicide attempt among
teenage girls the pandemic
is really the epidemic
is mental health among our kids and it's
all been
orchestrated by people with political
motives we have absolutely destroyed uh
their their childhoods we've taken away
their extracurriculars we've crushed
sports dreams for so many kids
we've isolated them we've caused them to
lose years of learning our special needs
kids by the way are suffering um the
most and and by the way we're torturing
them we're masking them as they go to
school this is outrageous and it shows
that we don't care or prioritize our
children as a society if you look at
china 94 million chinese have been going
to school since the pandemic started
this is a culture that values education
and clearly values their future
we are not and we're allowing political
actors very bad and corrupt political
actors um
run the lives of our children and ruin
them
so tyrus to rachel's point there i mean
how do we sort of compete with the
global world when we see that in
countries like china india and south
korea their investment in public
education and making sure their students
have the best education is far outpaces
america
well you can never really compare united
states to any other country because we
are a country of freedoms and we have
choices uh they don't have a choice in
necessarily in china to
home school or whatever but i will say
this as a parent and a former educator
homeschooling your own children and
teaching your own children is the
toughest job in the world because it's
just it's just really difficult and
masks in the school really hurt younger
children's development because you don't
realize how much children develop by
mimicking the teachers watching the
teacher phrase words how they say things
interactions those things those
movements that that we need it also has
to do with comfort uh the kids aren't
getting that so you know a lot of things
go wrong when you're not in the
classroom because you're just not
getting in that environment and you're
not getting the stuff that you need and
puts a lot of burden on mom and dad who
are working two jobs trying to play
catch up for when they couldn't pay rent
and et cetera so uh in school in-home
learning is is a really bad idea we need
our schools open and of course the
teachers always get the brunt of it but
it's the administrators who need to get
their act together
i agree with that administrators do need
to get their act together for my years
of journalism i know that when teachers
raise their voices they're raising it
for their students and
don't go anywhere the fastest is up next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else